the launch of a new Coal Mine in
Australia has divided the country
we have to take stronger actions Civil
Disobedience they are over here pleading
with our governments not to build new
coal mines we have a responsibility to
them
okay in India and create jobs across
Australia
the opportunities to feed the very very
best coal to those plants we have an
industry to be super proud of adani is a
revolution for us in central Queensland
because it's going to give up job
opportunities
but some fear the impact on Australia's
natural resources our own government is
destroying the Great Barrier Reef
we've lost about half of all the corals
of the Great Barrier
with communities bracing for impact in
their neighborhoods
yeah that's a water bomber he's gone
back to the airport to refill because
there's a fire still going over the back
deck
30 years when we've got raging bushfires
our Waters running out we can't grow
crops anymore
can the Australian government fight the
realities of climate change we're
getting more Cyclones we're getting
monsoonal events and climate change is a
big issue
[Music]
thank you
whether we lost in the court or whether
we lost it
come on
[Music]
Queensland Australia suburbs in the
Southeastern tip of the country are
engulfed in bushfires
catastrophic hot drought-like conditions
with wind speeds of 90 miles an hour
the fires spread fast
ler evacuated to safety while more than
20 homes are burnt to ashes
Rescue Services use aerial bombers to
douse the fires now spread over 4 200
Acres
an emergency is declared in vast suedes
of Queensland
2019 65 percent of Queensland was
declared to be in drought water supplies
for farms and homes are running dry
we travel to South
Suburban Town two hours from Brisbane to
investigate the impact of this heat wave
we'll find a number of homes are in
those two locations
that's James Morris from the New South
Wales rural fire service giving us the
latest update on those three
the severity of dwindling Water Supplies
can be caged by the signboards that
welcome us
as we arrive firefighters leave to douse
raging fires nearby
stanthorpe's community meeting is called
local police and the mayor have urgent
announcements and I can't stress enough
they are exclusion zones for safety
reasons we've got trees that have been
burnt out in those dry root systems that
could easily fall over on cars there's
power lines down you can see the
direction the wind was going and did it
with speed and with ferocious flames
the residents are holed up inside the
center
unsure if their homes have survived the
blaze
while outside
water bombing continues
as fires briefly subside
70 year old Kerry Stratford is allowed
back into her home
this was all I like on Friday night I
watched all this burn
and that house that's up the top there
is called the eagle cyst and I'm
surprised the eagle has to escape
because that was just burning
they had to call the firearies back
there yesterday to put some stuff out
but it got up to there it stopped there
said there must have been a heap of
firearies here
see that brown thing behind those rocks
that's melted there's a little car
that's a water tank
it's melted the top of its melted and
there's water in it that's how that's
how hot the fire was
Carrie's home miraculously survived
the fire stopped a few meters from where
she lives
when you're faced with not having a home
to come back with and that's the thing
that's still getting to me how lucky I
am can my home survived
I've got my late husband's voice on that
that's the only thing I've got of
hearing him talk
and that was when it snowed here
on the 17th of August 2015.
that's when it snowed
they evacuated those people out of there
the hardest thing is when you get the
knock on the door you know what's coming
from the police saying get out
and I said uh yeah I'll get I've got
everything packed everything ready and
he said well make sure you go
stanthorp's remaining water supply is
being sacrificed for firefighting
well the fact that we've been in dress
up here for so long we're having a
decent rain for
oh good two years now
um we've had space monogram our damn if
you go just have a look at Stone King
Dam
um that'll shock ya
because that's really shocking out there
we're on what severe water restrictions
will be out of water at the town here by
December
and I don't know if they're using the
water from our dam out there to fill a
fire bombers for this
I don't know where they're getting the
water from
the fires have shattered livelihoods
animal habitats water supplies and
agriculture
according to the climate Council of
Australia economic loss due to reduced
agricultural productivity is projected
to exceed 19 billion dollars by 2030.
211 billion by 2050.
and 4 trillion by 2100.
[Music]
reusing water has now become the only
way to survive the drought in many parts
of the country
show me bath water's in there because I
saved that
right and then I used to be bucket that
I've got there in my washing machine
I'll have to give that a rinse out this
this little Ash inside there from the
fire
from the ash to come through so I bucket
it with that bucket in there
wash my clothes in it
hang it down then put it out into the
bucket and then it goes on what plants
I've got to keep alive that's the only
way you water the plants you're not
allowed outside water your plants
let's not get the comedies evolving it
is changing
but I know that we're getting a few
degrees warmer each year you know we've
noticed a big increase in the in in the
global warming
but I don't know how you stop that
um there's something definitely
happening with the Earth
the state of the climate 2018 report for
Australia reveals a land surface
temperature increase of one degree
Celsius
that's led to hot dry conditions perfect
for bushfires
the science was saying then that if we
keep putting carbon dioxide and methane
into the atmosphere the temperature will
steadily increase there will be more
frequent extremes more very hot days
there'll be changes to rainfall patterns
so the science was saying 30 years ago
that Perth Adelaide Melbourne the
southern cities of Australia would get
drier and that's all happened
already Australia is ranked the seventh
highest carbon emitter per capita one
big reason coal-fired power plants
coal provides fuel for about 70 percent
of electricity production in Australia a
majority of these plants are located in
the state of Queensland
the state has a historical relationship
with coal
mining began here in the 18th century
behind most coal mining operations lay
years of struggle and toil
[Music]
Ty
and government and sparked development
across the country
[Music]
region is a shadow of its past with coal
jobs lost to automation
[Music]
still coal production continues to grow
to feed a hungry Market abroad
now instead of reducing Australia's
carbon footprint the Queensland Premier
has promised to open new coal mines in
her state
it's part of Anastasia Palace plan to
create thousands of new jobs
but at what price
[Music]
Australia is the world's largest
exporter of coal the commodity that's
aided the rise in temperatures worldwide
coal-fired electricity generation
accounted for 30 of global CO2 emissions
according to the International Energy
agency
resulting in record temperatures of 40
degrees Celsius in Australia
leaving the residents of Stanton
desperate for water
[Music]
as Rescue Services scrambled to save
lives queensland's Premier calls for an
emergency press conference
[Music]
so we have a number of families at the
moment that are actually going through
some really traumatic times so we are in
the process of trying to reach those
families we understand that they're all
safe but they will be going through a
lot of grief at the moment and I know
that our community will pull together
and definitely make sure that they get
back on their feet
we're filming a documentary from
Singapore from China news Asia just
wanted to get a comment from you about
the increasing number of coal mines
resulting in raising temperatures do you
feel that this is a direct impact of
that well we do know that climate change
has a big impact we knew that we're
getting more Cyclones we're getting
monsoonal events and climate change is a
big issue that everyone signs up to in
terms of keeping with the Paris tree
[Music]
queensland's coal industry has incensed
thousands of anti-call protesters across
the country
[Music]
investigate the politics of coal in
Australia
[Music]
two-thirds of extreme weather events in
the last 20 years were caused by human
activities
the Paris agreement signed in 2016 aimed
to curb emissions to minimize
temperature rise by 1.5 degrees
[Music]
friends continue
the world is likely to pass the 1.5
degrees Celsius Mark between 2030 and
2052 unless it finds a way to reach net
zero emissions
alarming situation the state of
Queensland announced new coal mines to
boost economy and create jobs
that's when Indian billionaire Gautama
madani announced plans to build a mine
at Carmichael a rural Outpost in the
Australian Outback
at the time Carmichael was to excavate
60 million tons of coal a year
that figure has since been scaled down
in effect what we're building now is a
10 million ton per annum Coal Mine we
just one of 125 operating coal mines in
Australia will be building 200
kilometers of Greenfield rail
construction to tie into the existing
Network so combined that will represent
around 2 billion Australian investment
to be able to get us into production and
we'll see that coming online in 2021
the mine would be located on the Galilee
Basin 160 kilometers Northwest of
Claremont
it will also feature a rail line
connecting the mine to the Abbott Point
tournament
the opening of the Carmichael mine is
expected to attract more investments in
the mining sector which activists say
would increase Greenhouse emissions that
trap heat and make the planet warmer
roughly 30 percent of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions came from
electricity production from coal and gas
in 2018.
Australia's mining sector wants the
backbone of the economy is in a Long
protracted slump
I take a lot more
clothes which are
there's no people in the town people
have to move away because there is
nothing here you know
um
so Generations got no future yeah that's
right the younger generation of Bowen
they've got nothing what do they turn to
I look around I mean the town's dead
completely completely dead
and the town needs employment real bad
there's nothing here for the younger
generation
they will leave town
adani announced thousands of jobs to be
created over the next few years
a prospect much welcomed by the mining
community
movement was centered around jobs
for the community
claremont's a very strong mining town I
think it was founded on copper mining
back in the 1800s and obviously then
gold and the people of Claremont
following the investment and in town and
the ability for those people to gain
jobs was very pro-adani I think I I
believe that mining is important I I
don't think that it's sustainable to
think that we can go straight from
coal-fired power to Natural Resources
like wind or solar but I think they
should work in hand
number of people locally I work in the
mining industry so
a lot of them are quite Keen I believe
to get more jobs going
um in that area
unemployment here hovers above nine
percent
compared to around six percent in
Queensland as a whole
that's why Bruce hedge is busy promoting
the adani mine
he started the go adani campaign
it's going to generate a lot of job
opportunities for Central Queensland the
Queensland government last year received
3.8 billion dollars in Carl royalties
from from from coal mines throughout
this state 3.8 billion dollars
uh lit next year the Queensland
government will spend at 3.9 billion
dollars on interest on loans now the
opponents of adani and coal are asking
us as a community to stop coal
exports stop the royalties coming
through I would love someone to tell me
where the 3.8 billion dollars is going
to come from
a town to void of jobs it's a polarizing
question of unemployment versus the
environment
there are questions about whether or not
the mine will pay appropriate royalties
or any royalties to our state government
and huge concerns about the fact that
there won't be that many jobs provided
and that the company has effectively
massively exaggerating exaggerated the
jobs that they say it would it would
provide
adani's initial promise of thousands of
new jobs was challenged by a court
testimony
an affidavit alleged that adani mining's
billion dollar Carmichael coal project
would have 483 full-time equivalent jobs
while Queensland as a whole would have
1206 full-time equivalent jobs
we'll see over 1 500 direct jobs created
during the ramp up and construction for
the mine and rail and a further 6750
indirect jobs so in total what we're
talking about is 8250 jobs invest in
injected into the Australian economy in
particular in Regional Queensland and
and specifically in areas that have
typically got high levels of
unemployment and we're talking about
areas that have approached close to 10
levels of unemployment so the Project's
certainly very important for Australia
and for Queensland and Regional
Queensland as it relates to jobs
jobs aside TV journalist Mark willacy
has news that's far less hopeful
he tracked developments on adani mining
elsewhere
the company was charged in Zambia with
polluting a major river and convicted
under Australian law if you have any
convictions or issues involving Mining
and you're in charge you have to declare
that that was not declared by this
particular adani executive at the time
and that culminated recently with adani
being charged and it's going to be
prosecuted for supplying false and
misleading information to the state
government here in Queensland
the state of Queensland imposed hundreds
of environmental conditions for the
Carmichael mine to adhere to
particular attention was paid to adani's
surface water use and the mind's
proximity to the great Artesian basin
the great Artesian Basin is the
is that the Water Resource in the world
stretching over 1.7 million square
kilometers
three thousand meters deep in places and
is estimated to contain 65 000 cubic
kilometers of groundwater
the Basin provides the only source of
fresh water to much of Inland Australia
underground coal mines rely on water to
reduce the risk of fires or explosions
by using it to cool The Cutting surfaces
of mining equipment and prevent cold
dust from Catching Fire
so we know about water being very
precious the adani mine would suck up as
much water as the rest of the users in
the whole catchment and they don't have
to pay as much for it because our state
laws are very lacks and give a whole lot
of freebies to mining companies for
reasons that we can go into later mostly
because they make generous donations to
both sides of politics we will not be
extracting water from the great Artesian
Basin we don't have any plans we don't
have any authorities or we don't have
any approvals to extract water from the
great Artesian Basin there are instances
where we'll have to extract groundwater
simply to be able to allow our mining to
be undertaken safely so it's simply for
safety reasons not for water extraction
reasons and outside of that all of our
water will be sourced from surface
sources
a former Queensland water Chief
estimates the mine may tap on a
substantial amount of the state's Water
Resources
when adani starts to extract coal and
intercepts the great Artesian Basin
aquifers water will flow out of those
aquifers into the mine pits and adani
are allowed to extract unlimited volumes
of water out of those mine pits to keep
their mining operations safe adani there
the modeled extraction of water over the
life of the mine is 270 gigalitres that
is equivalent to around about 55 percent
of Sydney Harbor
animal grazers like Bruce Curry rely on
the great Artesian Basin for their water
supplies
he lives in speculation a rural Outpost
in the Australian Outback
people can't exist without water if you
want to know what I'm talking about turn
your water supply off for two days and
try and survive regardless where you are
because what's happening here they're
turning our water off for perpetuity
when they destroy it it's gone forever
along with wife Annette the curries have
been running this farmland for
Generations this is the cow scene they
want to dig out it's the decal seam this
is where we draw our water from which is
the clemata sandstone and that is part
of the feed into the great Artesian
Basin the only thing is once they they
mine that coal seam out they have a
process called long wall Mining and what
it does is once the coal comes out they
just collapse all the strata above it so
what that'll do it'll drain that come
out of sandstone so basically it'll
destroy our water supply and it'll
destroy part of the feed into the great
Artesian Basin and which will impact on
the Integrity of the great Artesian
basin
worries about destroyed Water Supplies
inspired him to go on a fact-finding
walkabout overseas
he wanted to see what the future of
speculation might look like way out in
India
I went to India a few years ago to
actually have a look at the dining
operation and to talk to my main concern
was to talk to communities and Farmers
over in that area and get a good
understanding of the company that would
be coming when I was in India we went to
uh the adani's special economics home up
there in the Gulf of catch and I spoke
to fishermen there and they highlighted
to me there the pressures and the
impacts that they're suffering because
the tartars as well as the adanis had
built a power station there they
actually released their hot water out
into the ocean and which kills the
juvenile fish fish eggs and has a big
impact on the fishing communities that
are trying to survive on that source of
income
they're also not doing anything about
the fly ash that's coming out of their
smoke there's the stacks of the power
station and that fly ash is going across
Farmers lands
Bruce is unsure of similar damage to the
great utters Yen Basin is reversible
Once the mind starts and the dewatering
starts
whether that their findings are accurate
or not they cannot repair the damage and
the water is mined forever it's lost for
perpetuity regardless how big their
mistake is they cannot Rectify it they
cannot correct it and the impacts is
there for perpetuity
as the climate gets hotter and drier
water is even more precious
Farmers like Bruce want their
groundwater to be protected from any
damage
it is a shame that more people aren't
aware of what the great Artesian Basin
is all about it's you know one of the
biggest freshwater underground fresh
water sources in the world
and it's not polluted it's not
contaminated it's environmental
terrorism
for the money we've made
they could just through the flick of a
pen
take that away from us
not fair and it's not right like when
you went to India to have a look at
those poor Farms over there I don't
begin to understand
yes that
has affected their family
what will we do
[Music]
after a prolonged legal battle the adani
Carmichael mine has received the
environmental clearances it needs
but the opposition to its construction
continues
after the break we go underwater to
investigate the impact of rising
greenhouse gases on the Great Barrier
Reef
there's parts of the Great Barrier Reef
where you can drive on a boat or Swim
for kilometers without seeing a living
Coral
[Music]
adani wants to mine Australian coal
planning to export it back to India
adani is the largest private thermal
power producer in India with an
installed capacity of more than twelve
thousand megawatts
but they're ramping up production in
India adani stands to gain from the
rising need for power in developing
South Asia to fill the Gap in Supply
it's looking at Australian coal
[Music]
with a call will be chip through Abbott
Point Port operations it's been
operating for over 35 years in an
environmentally responsible way there's
thousands of ship movements through the
Great Barrier Reef every year so you
know the prospect that out the shipment
of our coal for the Great Barrier Reef
is going to have a direct impact on the
reef is just a falsehood
to export this coal adani signed a
99-year lease with Abbott Point Terminal
in 2011.
the deal cost adani roughly 2 billion
Australian dollars
a few years back there was a plan for
massive expansion of ports in the Great
Barrier Reef and there's basically six
big ports already and there was a Hope
by industry with their hand being held
by government to expand those ports to
ship more coal out and more liquefied
natural gas out through the Great
Barrier Reef to World Export markets now
the problem with making ports bigger and
deeper is that it requires a huge amount
of dredging so the huge impacts from
that dredging were a very very big
concern to Marine scientists
developments surrounding Abbott Point
Port are being keenly watched by Coral
expert Charlie verin
that's because of avid Point's close
proximity to the Great Barrier Reef
Marine Park
the Great Barrier Reef is the world's
largest coral reef system composed of
over 2 900 individual reefs large enough
that it can be seen from outer space
this is the world's biggest single
structure made by living organisms
reefs occupy just one percent of the
world's marine environment but they
provide a home to a quarter of all
marine species including unique fish
Turtles and algae
a large part of the reef is protected by
the Great Barrier Reef Marine Park
which helps to limit the impact of human
use such as fishing and tourism
Reef has lost more than half its Coral
cover since 1985.
high temperatures cause Mass Coral
bleaching due to warm ocean waters
is a
live environment everything competes
with everything else all the time so
corals have got this symbiosis with the
algae and that produces food and oxygen
but if you raise the temperature just
above the absolute
temperature tolerance that the corals
have the algae produced too much oxygen
and that kills them
we head out to investigate the effects
of rising temperatures on the Great
Barrier Reef
Charlie Veron is out to collect evidence
he's hoping the remaining Reef might be
spared from rising temperatures
parts of the Great Barrier Reef where
you can drive on a boat or Swim for
kilometers without seeing a living Coral
so the worst affected is total death of
the whole Reef and we see that in a few
reefs but the majority of reefs of the
Great Bear have not been wiped out by
any means but they have been quite
severely damaged
reefs protect coastlines from flooding
during extreme storms which is why
saving corals is critical
[Music]
as this is
every year the the increase that
threatens corals warms incrementally
just
each year it gets more and more
threatening and whether that kills the
coral or not depends on the amount of
time is exposed to these maximum
conditions maximum temperature
conditions that varies in patches all
over the ocean surface and it but it is
increasing year by year and that will
continue
Charlie has now retired but has spent
his life raising awareness of coral
bleaching
the other is direct lying direct telling
of Lies by politicians when for example
um
politicians say that Australia is
meeting all its obligations under the
Kyoto Under Paris agreement
Australia is going absolutely nowhere
near meeting its obligations now it is
not possible for a politician
to
to not know the truth because scientists
know the truth scientists tell the
politicians it's all in publications of
all different levels
so if you want to say we are meeting our
obligations under all these treaties
that have happened
um
you are not telling the truth and again
that's political
a report card by the government's
Australian Institute of Marine Science
wasn't encouraging
Rising water temperatures are likely to
cause more Coral bleaching producing
irreversible damage to the reef
scientists expect the coral May recover
over the next five to ten years but only
if another Mass bleaching event doesn't
occur during that time
unlikely
current
project climate change
in 2015 Australia Institute put the
Carmichael mine's expected emissions
over the next 30 years into perspective
it believes the annual carbon emissions
of the single coal mine would be three
times the average annual emissions from
New Delhi
double those from Tokyo
times that of Amsterdam
and 20 percent more than New York City
if the mine produces 40 megatons per
year
adding more carbon dioxide from mines
can potentially threaten thousands of
animal species that rely on the reef not
to mention the 6.4 billion dollars in
tourism revenue and 64 000 full-time
jobs the Great Barrier Reef provides to
Australia
[Music]
tourism operator Lindsay Simpson is
concerned about her livelihood
her boat tours serve International
tourists on a daily basis
if we add more Minds to that we are
looking at a reef that's already under
terrible threat we're looking at 70 000
people earning their money from tourism
who won't have anywhere to take anyone
to look at and I mean I've had
laughingly heard people say there's
something called disaster tourism
she decided to investigate adani by
traveling to India on her own and ended
up writing a book
[Music]
he was going to bring jobs for everyone
so he was going to make it all good
again and give lots of work now we all
know two percent of the Australia's
Workforce work in mines and if you think
about that it's an automated industry if
we look at how many of these people are
going to get jobs adani promised in
India he was going to give all these
jobs to locals he then imported workers
from Arisa and all these other places he
did not give the locals jobs he did for
the first year and there is evidence
he's giving work now that work is not
going to be there and if you look at in
terms of long-term work 1 300 workers is
what he was talking about versus 70 000
in tourism and those workers are only
going to be fly and fly out
has also sparked the native title
movement
every mining project in this country it
tends to be out in remote country and a
lot of that country is traditional
Aboriginal country and under Australian
law Aboriginal people from those areas
can claim what they call native title
and that's a form of guardianship over
these lands now no one has taken
guardianship over that land but there is
an Aboriginal group there that wants to
do that and they can legitimately apply
to the courts to do that
as a leader of the wangan and jagalingu
Native people who own this land Adrian
baragaba took adani to court
according to him the Carmichael coal
mine can harm around 30 000 hectares of
his community's traditional lands
eventually the Court ruled in favor of
adani Australia who are now seeking six
hundred thousand dollars in court costs
which would bankrupt baragaba
Adrian and his clan have now been barred
from entering their own lands
this always was Aboriginal land this
always was First Nations Sovereign land
because of our culture and how we
maintain our culture and we're not going
anywhere it's always going to be
Aboriginal land it's always going to be
our land
and if they can if they want if they
want to come out here and try to move us
and move our sacred site then they'll be
criticized this country will be
scrutinized over their treatment of
Aboriginal people the one and jaggling
people will no longer stand for this
bullying tactic from adani or from any
government in this country
Adrian's resist
to people's movement across Australia
the stop adani movement
they are over here pleading with our
governments not to build new coal mines
we have a responsibility to them and to
our children to have a safe future for
them to live in
thank you
the opposition to adani's Carmichael
mine has sparked to Grassroots
environmental movement across Australia
a loose group of environmental activists
students and common folk coming together
to pressurize adani to stop the mind
some of them have gathered at camp binby
it's called the stop adani movement
we've been given exclusive access to the
camp after much deliberation and
background checks
23 year old Amy Booth used to live in
Victoria but decided to join the stop
adani movement in the Australian Outback
people are going to be displaced by the
climate crisis so
I felt that me working in the city
taking sort of doing business as usual
working nine to five just
isn't where I want to be right now we
have a moral obligation to to act and to
stop this mind and to stop other
environmental problems going ahead
um so I'm I'm willing to put my life on
hold for the moment to do what I can to
stop projects like this from going ahead
because this isn't just about
this particular area every project that
is a fossil fuel project is adding to
CO2 in the atmosphere and that affects
the entire globe
thank you protesters like Amy believe
that if built adani's Carmichael mine
will add billions of tons of carbon
pollution to our atmosphere
in that context it is criminally
irresponsible to be proposing the
opening of new coal mines or new
coal-fired power stations and the adani
case is a particularly important one
because that would not just be a
significant Coal Mine in itself it would
potentially open up the whole Galilee
Basin as a new coal Province and there
are five or six other possible coal
mines in the pipeline that would be more
likely to go ahead if adani started
because the infrastructure for getting
the coal to port for managing water and
energy and infrastructure would be there
and that would reduce the startup costs
of other coal mines and that's why adani
has become a really symbolic issue in
Australia
call activists are now taking a more
Hands-On position
by physically blocking coltrane's mines
and machines
strategy now commonly known as a
lockdown
on 22nd July 2019
protesters set up a blockade outside the
Abbott Point port
about 20 members of the Environmental
Group gathered outside the port entrance
at 7am
this footage was filmed by Amy as a
co-protester's 22 year old Emily Starr
and 20 year old Matilda hesseline locked
themselves to a concrete Barrel
we wanted to start acting to show that
we weren't gonna but we weren't gonna
sit by and let this just happen
um
so we locked on in terms of we had our
arms clipped onto this um
little bar inside a
Barrel that was filled with cement and
then there was a PVC tube that our arms
would go down and be clipped onto
they stopped the supply of coal for
hours
that's when the Queensland police
stepped in
its tension mounted a French television
crew filmed the action from the site
I was willing to be arrested which I was
because a short-term inconvenience of
being arrested and being given a fine is
okay with me because the long-term
benefit of stopping this mind from going
ahead will be amazing
Amy continued filming events that day
the journalists and activists are
detained and charged with trespassing on
the railway line
the French crew were later released
after global condemnation grew but
they've since been barred from filming
anywhere close to the mine
they were embarrassed they think that
that was a mistake what the officers did
up there and I know from the police
commissioner down that was why the
charges were dropped so it was some
overzealous police policing by those
police officers are up up there
Emily and Matilda are now facing a court
hearing at Bowen
uncertain if they'll be allowed back
into camp binby
we're hoping that no curveballs will be
thrown when we get in there but it'll
likely just be sort of well we're hoping
it'll be a fine with no like restitution
audit against us but we're not sure what
it will be really magistrates can do
whatever they like
after now they come out of the Court
[Applause]
I think this is really important I
really liked hearing that he did
understand that even if he didn't
necessarily agree with it yeah yeah
I think that in Australia we have a huge
problem and in many places around the
world we have a huge problem where
the political systems are broken and
that's why we've come to do these kind
of actions because we feel like these
are the only sort of
things that can put enough pressure on
political systems to fundamentally
change rather than just sort of put a
Band-Aid on the issue
where are the critical point in history
there's no doubt that in ecological
terms we're booked on the Titanic we're
heading for the iceberg and there are
still irresponsible people both
literally and metaphorically throwing
coal in the boilers as if they wanted to
get there faster
foreign
particulates pollution is estimated to
shorten some 1 Million Lives annually
worldwide
one study even estimates premature
deaths arising from coal-related air
pollution could be as high as 52 000
people worldwide
but with solar and wind power slowly
creeping up there's been positive change
Cole's use has been on the decline in
Europe and the U.S a bit cheaper
alternatives
adani Australia is promoting solar power
as a means to bridge the gap between
coal emissions and the global push
towards renewable energy
rugby run which has an initial capacity
of 65 megawatts is located near morinbar
that's not a question of Renewables or
call it's Renewables and call and so
from our perspective we've already we've
got under over 2 385 megawatts under
cons under operation
uh in relation to solar and we've got
another 2 340 megawatts currently under
construction of solar capacity so in
short uh you know we've got uh in excess
of 4 700 megawatts of Renewables
capacity in our portfolio that's a
mixture of of solar principally solar
but we've also got hybrid in there as
well including wind so we see that uh
moving forward in order to meet the
developing world's energy demand
requirements it's going to continue to
require underpinning base load
coal-fired power generation in addition
to Renewables through the likes of solar
wind
um hydro and so forth
co-dependent has to come from within the
political sphere
the Australian greens run on four core
values ecological sustainability social
justice Grassroots democracy and peace
and non-violence
[Applause]
and the best thing about that whole
experience was that we could hear you
[Applause]
the greens have a plan to phase out coal
and create a jobs boom in the renewable
energy export industry we have great
economic potential in clean energy here
in Queensland in Australia globally we
know that there's more jobs in
Renewables we know that renewable energy
can do the job we've now got the battery
storage the solar thermal the ways of
making clean energy at 24 7 and
dispatchable there is no reason to not
go down that path and actually safeguide
Humanity
Australia's current Bushfire season has
taken 12 lives
destroyed millions of hectares of land
and wiped out nearly 500 million animals
with no signs of rains or temperatures
subsiding
stopping global warming will require
coordinated policies by national state
and local governments
and the development of climate-friendly
energy policies that are backed by
politicians and activists alike
Before Time runs out and the
irreversible effects of climate change
impact the very existence of humankind
foreign
Brazil's Amazon rainforest is being
devastated by fires
many of the farmers think the Amazon
shouldn't exist
a battle between economic development
and environmental concerns
it was planned fostered and executed by
the bolsonaro government
with thousands of miners invading the
forests to hunt for gold
popular
nearly 10 000 square kilometers of the
Amazon are destroyed in 2019.
displacing hundreds of indigenous
communities pushing them to the edge
foreign
CNA investigates why the lungs of the
world are being lost
[Music]
Sao Paulo Brazil
by 3 P.M the city is smothered by black
clouds of smoke
scientists eventually discover the
course
fires raging in the far north of the
country
thousands of miles away in the Amazon
rainforest
[Music]
official figures show more than 87 000
Amazonian fires are recorded in Brazil
in the first eight months of 2019.
an increase of 76 from 2018.
these fires destroyed ten thousand
square kilometers of the Amazon in 2019.
while the Brazilian government fails to
act
[Music]
the world responds with outrage
[Applause]
with criticism focused on newly elected
far-right president jair boltonaro
the rates we know today was not happened
by chance it was planned
fostered and executed by the Boston
Arrow government this is the truth
after bolsonaro's election the Brazil's
environmental agencies had their budget
slashed
his economic policies are focused on
developing the economy inside the Amazon
rainforest
a list of words so but aldum's
investigation Unearthed a bigger problem
lack of implementation of Brazil's
Forest laws
what is happen the company looks to
define a fine two or three million eyes
if I use good liars
I can stay years and years and years
without pay or is more expensive to pay
at semi time you receive the fine then
Roll and Roll and Roll again the fines
it's happened every time
from 1980 to 2019 penalties for cutting
trees down in protected areas totaled 17
billion US dollars
less than four percent of these fines
were collected
[Music]
corruption and the inability to collect
fines have encouraged more violators to
set up shop inside the Amazon
with hundreds of thousands of dollars to
be made
there's a lot of people working with me
there's the people from illegal logging
there's the people from Aggie business
there's a people link it to Illegal gold
mining for example there's the people
practicing Wildlife trash there's a lot
of people working with this chain of
crimes in the Amazon their first station
is one of them
the cleared land is used to produce beef
and Agri products
a large portion of which is exported to
parts of Asia
people need to understand that we are
all responsible for this so even people
far away in Pakistan in China
in Australia are also helping
with environment problems in the Amazon
because they are consumers they're
helping to consume products that are
coming from this region
worldwide forests still cover about 30
percent of the planet
but they are disappearing at an alarming
rate
between 1990 and 2016 the world lost 1.3
million square kilometers of forest
according to the World Bank
that's an area larger than South Africa
[Music]
is
we arrive in the state of para to
investigate the effects of the fires in
Northern Brazil
burnt down jungles now resemble a war
zone
Erica barenga is an environmental
scientist who's lived in the Amazon for
the last 10 years studying the
destructive force of the fires here
on the ground
and
The Roots grow inside the tube so every
three months you get a tube off the
ground put the soil in a sheet and then
we hand pick all the roots for one hour
and then we put the soil back in the
tube the mesh tube back in the soil and
then it's going to stay for another
three months so I can see in those three
months how many roots are produced how
many roots grow in there and then we can
estimate how much of the carbon it's
being allocated to the roots
Erica takes us for a walk inside a
protected area
to show us the impact of thighs on the
Amazon
so this is one of the main
reason and unborn part you can see that
we're not seeing many trees many big
trees that we associate with the Amazon
just all very thin
fast growing station
[Music]
the Amazon rainforest has 410 billion
trees in this region alone
with a total of 76 billion tons of
carbon stored in them
rise from this forestation would be
equivalent of a hundred years of the U.S
fossil fuel emissions that's how much
carb on the Amazon stores so it's a
vital component to fight climate change
by keeping the forest standing we are
locking all this carbon in the forest
and not putting back into the atmosphere
the study shows that they over 100 years
to recover the carbon stocks that are
present in this forest and we still
don't know how long it's going to take
for the biodiversity to cover
animals are being affected too
it's believed that there are about three
million different species of plant and
animal life in the Amazon
in the Amazon it's estimated that there
is 16
000 species of trees just in the
Brazilian part of the Amazon which is 60
of the whole Amazon we estimate to be 11
000 species
unfortunately I think that within my
lifetime if there's no political will
if we don't take strong positions the
Amazon is going to be gone
president bolsonaro wants to abolish
protection for indigenous lands
his calls have been echoed by miners
who've put self-preservation ahead of
Environmental Conservation
after the break we meet these miners who
have invaded the Amazon in search of
gold
[Music]
Brazil is one of the biggest gold
producers in the world
[Music]
with output reported at 81 million
kilograms in 2018.
but there is a new gold rush in Brazil
today
[Music]
one field by Soaring unemployment in
regions inside the Amazon rainforest
they are evading public lands lock the
trees do some gold mining and damage in
these areas or do some fishing and
hunting
as the planet loses the Amazon
rainforest at a rapid pace
there are miners on the other end of the
equation who are making increasing gains
locally known as Garden Perros their
Rising incomes develop cities like
bishoto de Acevedo
located in metal Cross of State their
gold producing hubs for Brazil's
lucrative gold industry
today miners have become more organized
creating cooperatives to hunt for gold
collectively
that was founded in 2008 by former Sao
Paulo Banker Gilson campboy
[Music]
he takes us for a tour of the Copa GV
gold mines that are under his
supervision
is
such gold mines are legal as part of the
Brazilian government strategy to
monetize the Amazon
[Music]
but drone images reveal the damage to
the environment
[Music]
this was once a lush green forest with
flora and fauna spread all across the
landscape
it's been replaced by energy guzzling
machines
alone as deep forested three thousand
square kilometers of Amazon rainforest
since 2008.
gold mining in the Amazon rainforest is
attractive for the high yield of gold
on average the concentration of gold is
0.5 grams for every one tonne of soil
inside the Amazon the yield is much
higher
[Music]
foreign
drama
[Music]
gold is found underground after topsoil
is removed
once a 10 meter ditch is ready the
miners at kobajibe Villages from rural
Brazil get to work guys
foreign
a hydraulic machine is parked near the
edge of this vast mining pit
that's been carved into the rainforest's
reddish brown Earth
[Music]
hundreds of gallons of mud sludge
produced by the miners is passed over
carpets
with the hope that gold flakes stick to
it
the carpet is then washed into drums and
the mud is taken to the final process
[Music]
after extensive padding
Mercury is used to extract gold from the
mud through a process called
amalgamation
foreign
worked without protective equipment
or procedures to help them discard the
Mercury safely
the amalgam of mercury and gold goes
through the final process
foreign
[Music]
the heat applied evaporates the Mercury
and gold is left in the pan
[Music]
Copa Jive mined 400 grams of gold today
this is distributed equally amongst
everyone at the mine
it will sell for 500 US dollars
in the poor Countryside that's a fortune
for a day's hard labor
number
[Music]
comments
is
foreign
who process it into gold bars
the final product is exported to
countries across Asia the Middle East in
America
earning billions of dollars in revenue
for the government
mines like copacile are legal and all
part of President bolsonaro's master
plan to monetize the Amazon
support is
but what about the Amazon
on the ground the Damage Done by legal
Minds is irreversible
species
foreign
is supposed to restore the forests once
the mine is closed
so Gilson takes us to a restored part of
the mine
it's turned one area into a fish farm
while planting trees in another
um foreign
[Music]
as greed takes over concern for the
environment many miners are going for
the big bucks by starting their own
minds
deep inside protected territories away
from the authorities
after the break we dig deep into illegal
Mining and meet the people whose lands
have been invaded in the protected
forests of Brazil
[Music]
Brazil's Amazon rainforest is one of the
planet's best defenses against climate
change
it absorbs billions of tons of carbon
dioxide
a deforestation for logging Mining and
for farming crops in livestock has
devastated it
in the last 10 years the rainforest has
lost an area the size of 8.4 million
soccer fields
want to use indigenous lands to expand
operations and make more profits
they're pushing for a change in
Brazilian law
allowing firms to mine inside protected
lands and Indigenous reserves Across the
Nation
is
economically
despite having protected status
indigenous territories are already
facing an invasion
in Para State alone Brazilian
authorities estimate that 30 metric tons
of illegal gold worth about 1.1 billion
US Dollars has been excavated
that's six times more than the legal
amount of gold traded in Brazil
is
foreign
this mining boom could lead to the
extinction of indigenous communities
that have weathered centuries of
calamities in Brazil's rainforest
roughly 900 000 indigenous people live
in Brazil less than 0.5 percent of the
population
good
they belong to 400 tribes and speak more
than 270 languages
one such tribe facing illegal mining in
their protected areas are the mundaruku
we travel 16 hours to the city of
buburen
temperatures
indigenous protected Land by the
Brazilian government that have been
invaded by illegal gold miners and we're
going to meet the chief of the tribe to
understand the extent of the problem
[Music]
look
up
yo
Juarez is the chief of the munduruku
tribe
he leads nearly 14 000 members who have
splintered into dozens of small villages
scattered across a territory slightly
larger than 3360 soccer fields
they've lived here for thousands of
years
foreign
[Music]
that's why Juarez has to create borders
or more commonly known as demarcations
to identify his tribe's indigenous lands
motivated by the surging International
price of gold
miners choose to prospect for gold in
protected reserves to evade taxes
it's estimated that nearly 50 000
illegal miners are working inside para
State alone
[Music]
shopping
Elementary
[Music]
see some of the plugs here so now
foreign
indigenous people from their land is
forbidden under article 231 of Brazil's
Constitution
but the bolsonaro government is planning
to build dams and infrastructure in the
tapayos River Basin to boost the economy
armed with machetes Juarez and his crew
ensure the conservation of 178 000
hectares of Amazon rainforest
ations
to
foreign
takes us to one such illegal mining site
an hour's Boat Ride On the tapayos River
as we arrive we spot a mining transport
truck
we tread carefully as most miners are
armed and do not like visitors
miners in protected areas such as this
excavate land deep inside the forests
away from the authorities keeping clear
of any inspections
foreign
[Music]
as we reach an abandoned mining pit
the extent of the devastation can only
be caged from high above
kilometers of protected Amazon
rainforest are now mere ditches
[Music]
nobody
yeah he is
[Music]
we don't venture too far we've been
warned that the illegal miners may open
fire
five tribal leaders have already lost
their lives in this battle
but with little enforcement of the law
the destruction continues
um
[Music]
if I
is
not
heels
is
a map published by an NGO shows illegal
mining sites in 37 indigenous
territories
in total nearly 2 300 illegal mining
sites with sophisticated infrastructure
have been found in protected areas
Juarez fears for his life and his
community
currently in Brazil mining on indigenous
territories is totally prohibited
the Amazon contains about 20 percent of
the world's total volume of river water
more than 80 percent of the world's food
has its origins in this rainforest
apart from tearing down native forests
miners have also started digging for
gold in the rivers contaminating these
waterways with Mercury
we have reports on firsts dolphins and
Indigenous tribes hardly contaminated by
Mercury
the humidity
launched by the first
runs in the atmosphere and drops like
rain all over Brazil Argentina South
America always connected dredging for
gold disrupts Rivers toxic pollutions
seep into plants animals and people
foreign
[Music]
Elementary
um
Juarez in this community can no longer
fish in the river they have to hunt for
food on land
researchers found 92 percent of all hair
and fish samples collected here had high
levels of mercury resulting in
abnormalities in the central nervous
system of infants
[Music]
so Juarez has decided to take things
into his own hands
after the break we followed the
munduruku as they plan to invade
Brazil's Congress to pressure
politicians to take action
s
[Music]
Brazil's president Jaya boltonaro plans
to reduce indigenous territories in the
Amazon rainforest
the tribes are being sacrificed to help
boost the economy to create jobs
the mining sector is encroaching into
the rainforest and the hunt for gold has
begun
in 2018 Brazil's gold exports increased
150 percent on an output of 95 tons
with demand Rising miners are pushing
deeper inside protected forests
radically changing the landscape forever
this is why indigenous tribes have
decided to invade the federal capital
Brasilia
Alexandra Cora a muduruku indigenous
activist is leading the charge
Alexandra has arrived in Brasilia the
country's capital to meet her munduruku
clan
[Music]
local schools have been turned into a
makeshift camp
these 50 mundaroku tribals plan to visit
Brazil's Congress to meet politicians
and demand that their lands protected
under Brazil law be left alone
is
foreign
[Music]
National Institute for space research in
2018 alone five square kilometers of
indigenous munduruku land was deforested
in 2019 the tree Massacre increased to
15 square kilometers
Alexandra believes illegal miners have
the backing of politicians
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
next day the tribe prepares for battle
they believe bolsonaro's rhetoric has
encouraged the advance of the miners
deeper into indigenous territory
problems
thank you
the munduruku are on their way to
Congress to block a bill that will allow
mining companies to operate inside
indigenous lands legally
it's a key campaign promise of president
boltonaro if approved indigenous tribes
in their way of life may be gone forever
[Music]
an economic recession in Brazil has
driven large numbers of unemployed
Villages into the jungle to hunt for
gold
and the price is being paid by
indigenous people
[Music]
arrived at Brazil's Congress the main
legislative body of the country
this movement is helped by the country's
only indigenous congresswoman Joanna
wapichana
she's only the second indigenous woman
to have ever been elected to congress
there is
organizations
594 Congress Representatives only three
show up
[Music]
the others celebrate a football team's
participation in a local League
[Applause]
[Music]
in a separate chamber Alexandra makes an
impassioned plea for the rights of the
munduruku
um
[Music]
as Brazil is polarized on the issue of
mining in the Amazon
other Industries are coming up with
Solutions
[Music]
Lorraine started paxa a cattle ranching
firm in June 2015.
he helps Brazilian Farmers with
sustainable cattle farming
according to the Amazon Institute some
12 million hectares of cattle field have
been degraded in the Amazon region
create new grazing land vast expanses of
the Amazon are cleared
to date an estimated 70 percent of
deforested Amazon has been converted
into pasture land
but paxa offers a solution
so here we use rotated grazing rotated
grazing means that we have a production
module that has several divisions and
the cattle we stay in one division for
just a few days and then goes to the
other one and then to the other one
and while the cattle does all this cycle
then the first one is resting
this allows
first the fact that the cattle always
has access to the best part of the plant
only the leaves doing a efficient
production we don't need any more to
clear any more land many big
corporations over the world have made
commitments
to remove a deforestation from the
supply chains
from 2010 to 2017 Brazil's beef exports
climbed 25 percent to 1.5 million tons
with Hong Kong importing the most
to accommodate Global beef demand cattle
ranchers are driving their herds deeper
into the Amazon rainforest
since operations began in Alta Floresta
paxa has restored 10 000 hectares of
pasture land
now runs 20 Farms that sustainably
manage cattle 34 000 head in 2017 alone
for the wrong Reinventing cattle feed
was another necessity of the hour
methane emitted by livestock accounts
for about 5.5 percent of worldwide
greenhouse gases
greenhouse gases that increase global
temperatures
when they have this poor diet only based
on pasture and a low quality pasture
then they have a lot of production of
methane when we do the reform of the
pastures and then we enter with this
supplement
we change the diet of the the animals so
we have two benefits one is to reduce by
more or less 40 percent the amount of
methane that is emitted by The Animals
so when you consider the method of the
animals and also the carbon from the
soil all together we reduce the
emissions by 90 percent
oh
today the deforestation in the Amazon
claims an area the size of two football
fields a minute if consumption patterns
don't change
fifty percent of the Amazon may vanish
by 2030. destroying one of the world's
largest carbon sinks
protecting existing rainforests and
aggressively planting new ones may be
the only way forward and perhaps one of
the last few ways to help save this
planet and all who call it home
[Music]
foreign
Pakistan's Himalayan glazes are melting
at the fastest rate in human history
nearly 36 percent of its ice sheet will
be gone by 2100.
foreign
between
[Music]
Pakistan
um
impacting the water needs of more than 2
billion people in South Asia
Rising heat waves in mega cities
increasing water consumption communities
are fighting over dwindling supplies
I don't think many pakistanis know how
bad it is
could an ambitious tree planting Drive
save the melting glazes
so we went to the store 10 lakh actors
in Pakistan
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Pakistan's largest city with a
population of 20 million
the economic nerve center of the country
is brought to a standstill
strikes the southern Port City in June
2015.
with temperatures as high as 49 degrees
Celsius
the Blazing Sun causes total Mayhem
unaware and unprepared more than 2 000
people across Karachi perish from
dehydration and heat stroke
hospitals are ill-equipped to deal such
a calamity
the Abbasi Shaheed Hospital Mortuary
Runs Out of Space
as a result Mass graves are dug to
dispose off the bodies
[Music]
memories of 2015 have come back to haunt
Karachi today
wave has returned with average daytime
temperatures hitting 49 degrees
since government declares a city-wide
emergency
we head out to the Abbasi Shahid
Hospital's heat stroke unit
to our surprise there are no heat stroke
patients today
anyway
s
foreign
government officials are also better
prepared
mobile units equipped with water sprays
are deployed strategically during the
hotter hours of the day
despite the 49 degree temperature today
no casualties are reporting
foreign
This Is The New Normal in Karachi
an international climate report puts
Pakistan at number six on the list of
top 10 countries most affected by
climate change
[Music]
and in mega cities like Karachi lack of
trees miles of asphalt roads and tall
buildings have increased heat absorption
making matters worse is an unchecked
growing population in poorly plant yet
densely populated settlements
this
Karachi um
is this spectacular example of
population explosion to the small
coastal city which became the capital
city and it is now the largest city so
population you have more people you need
more water your more shops and factories
you need more also mismanagement
Karachi did not manage to protect its
watercourses
with Rising temperatures the massive
population of Karachi consumes more
water
Karachi needs 1.1 billion gallons daily
to supply water to roughly 20 million
residents
of the waterboard the city's Water
distributor is only able to provide 550
million gallons per day
[Music]
Muhammad Arif is a resident of karangi
his tap Runs Dry
[Music]
um
broken water distribution lines multiply
the problem for karachiites
Arif arrives at the main distribution
pipeline of the government a hundred
meters from his home
plans to divert water to his home with
the aid of hoses and a handheld motor
is
foreign
[Music]
so what does the Water Board karachi's
Water distributor have to say
basically Smith transmission
is foreign
foreign
[Music]
according to the Karachi water and
sewage board 42 of water is lost in
distribution before reaching consumers
so where does all this water go
we go in search of karachi's water
Thieves for an answer to this question
after much deliberation we finally
convince a water Thief to take us to a
theft point
we filmed the process secretly yeah
thank you
[Music]
we're inside uh illegal
um
theft area this is how water is going on
the water Thief takes us to a congested
slump
[Music]
in the meantime The Mastermind arrives
to explain how it works
foreign
he takes us to where he steals the water
from
water that he then sells at exorbitant
rates while government officials get
their cut
[Music]
demand Supply is
thank you
theft corruption and disrepair hamper
water axes for millions in Pakistan's
largest city
it costs millions of dollars in losses
to the National exchequer
stolen water is diverted from the poor
to the rich who can pay more a
short-term solution the city developed
for its water needs were water tankers
that now control much of karachi's water
distribution
more than 10 000 tankers operate in the
city under government control
making an estimated fifty thousand
delivery trips to Consumers across
Karachi each day
but with few checks and balances
excessive bribes kick in when heat waves
hit Karachi
allowing tanker drivers to jack up rates
as they will
delivery of a 1 000 gallon water tanker
now costs between 12 and 18 per trip
this is a steep price especially for
larger poorer families
who spend a third of their income on
Stolen water
a global study projects that nearly 5
billion people will live in water stress
regions by 2050.
while the United Nations estimates that
water shortages can displace hundreds of
millions of people as early as 2030.
water is a massive political issue in
Karachi and Corruption is in the middle
of it all
with one political party depriving the
water needs of another party's
constituency
it is a pretty reality a disaster
or is
a resources
and it is really alarming
while solving karachi's Water Crisis
seems like a distance pipe dream the
residents of Karachi are left with no
option but to buy stolen water
[Music]
after the break we embed with the karate
water task force in their efforts to
stop water theft
foreign
Pakistan's largest city has an epidemic
capitalize on climate change related
water shortages karate's black market
for water is thriving
millions of dollars worth of government
water is being stolen and sold to people
who can pay a premium
so the Karachi water board has stepped
up their efforts
[Music]
Chief security officer tabish Raza heads
the task force against water theft
uh
um
[Music]
foreign
everybody
this is
foreign
[Music]
a water motor is confiscated in the raid
as tabish explains the kind of money
Changing Hands in karachi's legal water
industry is
foreign
a textile Factory is stealing and
reselling water
[Music]
hold on
foreign
the illegal pump from the ball is taken
out and confiscated
yeah
this is a daily routine for tabish and
his team
they arrest the perpetrators and Destroy
10 pumps a day
but did a city of 20 million people and
with limited resources the Karachi water
board can only play catch-up with the
thieves
and climate change will only worsen
karachi's water worlds
grammar change will mean more
floods it will mean more droughts
it will mean heat waves like the one we
saw in Karachi two years ago it will
mean reduction in the quantity and
reduction and the quality
of water both are serious there will be
significant Health impacts
soaring temperatures in South Asia are
reaching Peak levels due to Rising
greenhouse gas emissions the heat is
melting the water wall of South Asia the
Himalayas that Supply water to the rest
of the subcontinent
the glaciers in Northern Pakistan in the
disputed region of Kashmir are the
biggest ice sheets outside the polar
regions
these ice sheets are melting
we drive 15 hours from Islamabad to
gulmit a village in Northern Pakistan to
investigate its impact
according to a new study 36 percent of
the glaciers found in the region will be
gone by 2100.
Sitara Parveen is a glaciologist who has
studied these ice sheets for a decade
this was once the area which had plenty
of water from this Glacier because the
glacier was much higher and even up to
the level of this Marines you can see
here this Moraine it shows that the the
level was much higher so the water was
recharging these irrigation channels the
Glaciers are very sensitive to climate
they act according to the temperature
and the precipitation when it's hot it
melts a lot
[Music]
since 1988 the Snow Line in Northern
Pakistan has receded by 1.1 kilometers
what scientists and glaciologists
thought was impossible in one thousand
years
has happened within 30.
if Global emissions stay at current
levels future Generations may never see
ice in South Asia
these Glaciers are also important for
these farmers who are living here who
depend on these agricultural for their
livelihoods because you can see this
that this is very moistured deficit area
less rainfall in these plain areas where
these Glacier the people practice
agriculture so it's not possible without
the water from these glaciers
nestled in the karakora mountains as
high as 23 000 feet Village communities
like these are vulnerable
[Music]
Lakes forming within the glaciers often
burst causing flash floods destroying
life and property Downstream
[Music]
a local resident and tour guide takes us
to the Culkin Glazier
due to pollution fine particles of black
carbon are deposited onto white Glaziers
speeding up the melting process
ities
[Music]
after a three-hour Trek over ice we
arrive at the gulcan glacier one of the
largest in Northern Pakistan
streams of water run down into the
crevices
collecting at the bottom of the glacier
as the sun blazes onto the ice sheet
Xiao could point out this water collects
into a massive Lake within the glacier
that burst any time and flood the
village Downstream
is
foreign
local officials hurriedly built a
concrete wall to prevent the water from
bursting the banks
but they stood no chance in front of the
Savage wall of water that came hurtling
down at the village
Tariq remembers that fateful day
foreign
Tariq believes more than 30 homes were
washed away and if proper planning was
done they could have been saved
uh
alhamdulillah
80 percent as it is
200 feet
200 feet is nothing more damage
takes us to the glacier
it's the next disaster in the making
this black glacier is physically moving
five to six meters a day Downstream to
the Village to due to Rising
temperatures
and local communities are concerned if
it's going to destroy homes again
movement
the region is expected to face Mass
Water shortages in around 50 years when
glaciers become too small
after the break take you to the highest
militarized Zone in the world
where India and Pakistan are battling a
war on top of a glacier
Pakistan has been bestowed with five of
the biggest rivers in the world
the mighty Indus Jayla janab Ravi and
sudlich that have cascaded down the
plains of the Punjab for hundreds of
years
[Music]
these rivers are formed by melting
glazes in the karakoram and Himalayan
ranges
one such Glacier is nestled between
India and Pakistan in the Eastern
karakoram range in the Himalayas
it's called the xiachin Glazier and is
claimed in full by both Pakistan and
India
it's been disputed territory after the
two countries split in 1947.
the contended area is a sheet of ice
nearly 1 000 square miles in Toten
unable to settle the land dispute
diplomatically troops were amassed on
top of the glacier by both countries
Pakistan and India have spent millions
of dollars a month to keep troops posted
here
at 6 700 meters it is the highest
militarized Zone in the world
overlapped between in Pakistan
transcends Downstream
to the waters that continue to flow from
India to Pakistan
after partition in 1947 India and
Pakistan were unsure of how to share
water hence the Indus water treaty was
signed in 1960 between then Indian Prime
Minister jawaharlal nehru and Pakistani
president
Ayub Khan in Karachi
brokered by the World Bank the tree the
tree he allowed both countries to use
the water available in the Indus system
of rivers
the true country is because of historic
problems and animosity and hostility
could not agree on joint management so
it was considered that a second
partition
should take place
Pakistan got the rights to use the three
Western Rivers the Indus jalam and tanab
exclusively while India won the rights
to use the three Eastern Rivers the Ravi
sutledge and brias
but today tensions between the nuclear
neighbors of a Kashmir is putting
pressure on this water treaty
the Hindu nationalist BJP led by Prime
Minister Modi has rattled things Modi
now wants to build dams to block the
flow of water into Pakistan
making the Indus River a hot spot that
might escalate into a nuclear war
[Music]
I think the next fight would be on water
actually the world is going to fight on
a water and we never realized Indus
water treaty when it was done in 70s
that was the time that we could solve
this problem but India always more
authoritative never obey the rules
even if they are Internationals so this
treaty remained what would I say it
remained just in the books
Pakistan semi-arid climate means more
than 90 percent of harvests depend on
irrigation
you're going to have pakistanis
receiving this water
so when you receive less water you blend
the supplier so there is a potential
um uh source of conflict and the
Secretary General in his report the U.N
Secretary General
made a specific reference to India and
Pakistan and said that climate change is
likely
to put pressure
on the endless water treaty which has
served the two countries
well for almost 60 years
spiteful full-blown Wars India and
Pakistan have never had a water War
but the situation in the disputed region
of Kashmir is escalating
a majority of Pakistan's Rivers
originate from Indian administered
Kashmir and in August 2019 India did the
unthinkable
India's dams released nearly 6 million
liters a quarter per second into
Pakistan without intimation
the Pakistani province of Punjab was
flooded drowning hundreds of Acres of
agricultural land
Abad reacted angrily it claimed this
unexpected release of water into the
river soledged that flows from India to
Pakistan was part of an attempt by New
Delhi to flout the Indus water treaty
this was followed by the revocation of
article 370 in 2019 to eliminate the
special status of Indian administered
Kashmir an area claimed by Pakistan is
[Music]
as geopolitical realities mix with a
potential water wall the reaction in
Pakistan administered Kashmir is intense
[Music]
travel to pakistan-controlled Kashmir at
the front line of this complex battle
where campers are reaching boiling point
is
[Music]
[Applause]
such rallies in Pakistan administered
Kashmir have become routine
frequent protests are putting pressure
on the Pakistani army to liberate Indian
administered Kashmir and secure the
supply of water for Mainland Pakistan as
well
[Music]
um
of Pakistan administer
administered fears that Prime Minister
Modi May usurp the Indus water treaty
and leave Pakistan in a drought-like
situation
in a never-ending conflict between two
nuclear-armed countries more than 50 000
kashmiris have lost their lives
will the water dispute claim more
after the break we look at Prime
Minister Imran Khan's billion tree
tsunami that's being built as the idea
that could save the region
thank you December 2019
New Delhi is in the grips of an intense
smog
the air quality index reads as high as
one thousand
the smog transcends the Border over to
parts of Pakistan
a Blame Game erupts between politicians
on either side of the Border
first job it's a
sun to burn the rice husk it never
stopped at people for the or the batamas
door for a breakdowns next time through
our foreign Ministry for this Kashmir
issue or for any bilateral talk third
agenda should be this smog and all this
pollution between India and Pakistan and
again I'm saying Pakistan has done a lot
India has not
NASA satellite data shows a heavy
concentration of fires on the Indian
side and far fewer on the Pakistani side
of the Border
the end result was a deadly Smog and
downgrading of air quality across the
subcontinent particularly in India
cricket star turned prime minister Imran
Khan's surprising response grabbed
headlines
party the Pakistan tarike insoft
spearheaded billion tree tsunami in 2014
at a cost of 169 million dollars
this was the Pakistani government's
response to the challenge of global
warming in South Asia
Pakistan has the lowest tree cover in
the region giving it more reason to
reforest a billion trees were planted
from 2014 to 2018.
but prime minister Khan isn't stopping
here he is vowed to plant 10 billion
trees in the next five years of his
government
tsunami but before that it was actually
brilliantry tsunami uh it was started by
the Prime Minister Imran Khan at that
time he was not a prime minister
and we had a one Province government
that was called kpk this was the first
green initiative that our country
started in 73 years it was one of the
different
and the finest uh project that any
government on provincial level started
so it was brilliantry tsunami
and it has made the marks on the on the
history on on the world
[Music]
the plan is to increase the forest cover
in the country and attract rains that
will reduce Rising temperatures
total Pakistan has restored 350 000
hectares of forest and degraded land
to surpass its Bond challenge commitment
[Music]
stance Vision 2025 is aiming to work on
better Water Management as well
due to traditional farming techniques
two-thirds of irrigation water is lost
through system leakages across the
country
that's why farmers like ashik bangus
have stepped in the residents of
Islamabad bangus decided to introduce
drip irrigation into Pakistan's
traditional farming system
to save the time and water and to give
water to the plants up to the standard
requirement not less nor excess yes
it is
foreign
Pakistan is among the six countries that
will be most affected by global warming
and a rising population calls for
measures to protect natural resources
foreign
[Music]
2025 has been marked as the year when
Pakistan may turn into a water scarce
country
unable to meet its water needs
I think Reservoir storage capacity
cannot sustain Pakistan's population
boom while River flow has also been
reduced over the years
Pakistan can get more economic social
and environmental benefits from better
water use
but it's subject to continuous reforms
to improve water use efficiency and
Service delivery and create awareness
among the general public
[Music]
in Lahore pakistanis are rising to the
challenge to put pressure on politicians
across Pakistan to do more
people don't understand how bad it is
there are just this year there were
floods unexpected rains in Punjab that
wiped out a substantial portion of the
wheat crop that affected people's
livelihoods and for a country where a
quarter of the population is actually
near the poverty line a single event
like that one rain is the difference
between getting a square meal a day or
not
in a country beset with problems only
four percent think that climate change
is an issue
raphae wants to change this attitude
attitude he's taking his family to The
Climate march to raise awareness amongst
kids in Pakistan
no we're going to be helping organize it
the children who are organ leading the
March students not us
[Music]
safer
all right so we've got Martin near
Valley currently under progress
the Youth of Pakistan are concerned
about their future when the impact of
climate change May worship
and it's been spectacular of the
Cleveland Panthers
[Music]
more than 5 000 marches take place
worldwide along with Lahore on the same
day
the climate strike is the largest ever
Collective call to action in the world
my government is the biggest polluter in
history and should be doing something
about it but instead president Trump
doesn't even believe in climate change
and wants to pull us out of the Paris
agreement I find it completely
unacceptable especially because my
friends and in-laws here in Pakistan are
the ones who are already suffering the
most from the impacts of climate change
[Music]
foreign
Pakistan contribute contributes less
than one percent of world's greenhouse
gases yet it is the world's sixth most
vulnerable country affected by climate
change
while it must develop a robust foreign
policy that allows it to effectively
negotiate climate issues with its
neighbors Pakistan's march to solve its
climate problems has begun
thank you
[Music]